[Music]
at the level of this spectator
consciousness the chorus the indifferent
ground on which the performance takes
place
spirit does not appear in its scattered
multiplicity but in the simple direction
of the notion its substance therefore
shows itself torn asunder merely into
its two extreme powers
these elementary universal beings are at
the same time
self-conscious
individualities heroes who place their
consciousness into one of these powers
find in a determinateness of character
and constitute the effective activity in
actuality of these powers
this universal individuation descends
again as will be remembered to the
immediate reality of existence and
presents itself to a crowd of spectators
who have in the chorus their counterpart
or rather their own thought expressing
itself
paragraph
735 is a short one but there's a lot
going on here it's a rich paragraph and
i think it's
important to think of it as following on
the heels of the previous paragraph
introducing
the chorus looking at the function
of the chorus in relation not just to
the other narrative we could call them
personae the gods and heroes
but especially the audience themselves
the chorus plays a kind of mediating
role that is signaled at the beginning
and at the end of this
paragraph so he says at the level of
this spectator consciousness and then
miller interpolates there
the chorus in brackets but i think
that's quite
reasonable
both the chorus and the audience are
spectator consciousnesses
zhu shaondin bavostein right zeus
schaunden looking upon
watching also listening as we've seen as
well
and he goes on to say that
this is the and it's kind of an
interesting translation here
in different ground we just saw the
chorus as being a ground aboden a base a
foundation for the action of the play
indifferent glyc
gultegan right
worth about the same right so
it's not indifferent as lacking any
value whatsoever but it's all more or
less of the same value any particular
person that you would pull out of the
chorus is you know an individual in with
like a lowercase i not a hegelian
individual and you could pick any any
old person right this is what we call
joe blow or we used to joke around in in
you know uh my family's canadian french
jacques mataras right as the everyman
any person
and so that's you know good to keep in
mind notice that at the end he makes
this connection really clear and he
talks about
a crowd a manga of spectators
zushawanden
who have in the chorus
two things
and here the language is very important
right
their counterpart gegen build and we'll
come back to that word in a moment or
rather hegel says their thought
expressing itself and there he's
actually so uh
what is the german for stellang right a
word that's come up here before a word
that is very important in terms of the
entire religious uh consciousness
development towards ultimately towards
like the community and philosophy
towards the concept away from
mere
picture thought in this case uh the
translation for
uh foreshadowing is thought expressing
itself
and that's a little bit more like a
concept now isn't it
but
this is
um
what is being
provided here this is all for stellang
right the
heroes the extreme powers that are
involved but also the audience
themselves and the chorus are involved
in this act of representing
and so if we want to be a little bit
jokey we could say that the chorus is
the representative
of
the audience right or representatives
counterpart gig and build right so
against them
um
[Music]
not not just the counterpartisan like
having
equal functions or opposed functions
but again there's a representative
characteristic here let's look at what's
happening in the rest of the paragraph
he says that
at the level of this spectator
consciousness and literally just in this
spectator consciousness the indifferent
ground in which the performance the
forced
that's performance here takes place
spirit does not appear in its scattered
multiplicity but in the simple direction
of the notion and as i was reading this
again i was thinking well isn't that
typical hegel right this is part of what
makes hegel sometimes a target
for other thinkers who want to say there
is multiplicity though right it's not so
simple as a binary
this versus that
in this case we even see that the binary
is really not even that much of an
opposition right
so
hegel over and over and over again
throughout the work seems to love dyads
you know this i think comes out of the
hegelian
notion of opposites coming out of the
very same thing which a lot of people
will read as antithesis not always
antithesis in hegel but you know we so
we need to be careful about that it's
definitely part not part of thesis
antithesis synthesis the simplistic
misreading of hegel but you can say that
hegel really does like twos and threes
and he's brought up a little bit earlier
and he's going to talk in the next
paragraph about this multiplicity this
monic faulty kite
that was brought up earlier with respect
to the gods and with respect to the
political community
instead we're going to have
a dyad of what he's calling extreme
powers extreme meaning at one side right
extrema not in the sense of like being
the greatest power and power here is
mocked so we have this direction of the
notion direction we could just say
doubling splitting because the the
german for it is enzyme right zai tu and
zvayum uh
emerging into two that are at perhaps a
distance from each other of the notion
or the concept the begeth
so the concept of spirit is splitting
into two splitting into two how well on
this ground for the spectators in the
representation
representing what well these like we
just said extreme powers let's go back
to the text hegel says
it's torn asunder into its true extreme
powers right it's it's ripped um
um these elementary
universal beings
now beings
veisin right so essences we could also
say right um these these two elementary
and the word there elementary sha is
just a cognate
universal all gemini right um
beings
in the story in the the
tragedy in the narrative
um what are they
well they're also individualities
and here
it's very interesting because hegel uses
individual right
and this is the plural so we have um
self-conscious
individualities
and we have them in the plural we don't
have them singular
and they are the
heroes the elden right um the
if you want to say protagonists and
antagonists um
they are the
uh
zeus and prometheus you know uh we're
talking about um
prometheus bound they are
who else would we say agamemnon and
clydominestra and i guess these along
for the ride and arrestees uh watching
along they are
crayon and antigone in the antigone
they are
you know it gets a little bit difficult
when we get to some of the tragedies
who is it in the ajax is it ajax
and odysseus is it ajax and athena
uh you know sometimes it can be a little
tricky to make these fit hegel's schema
in any case right he says heroes
who place their consciousness into one
of these powers and what do they find in
it
so this is where it gets quite
interesting
determinateness of their character
bistim tight a determination
of who it is that they are determining
them not just as sort of abstract
qualities but through what it is that
they actually do they you know odysseus
um or actually let's take somebody else
instead much more fateful
oedipus
in oedipus rex
is going to make a choice
i i need to punish this guy who killed
the king
the guy who i've replaced and you know
married his wife and made a bunch of
kids with uh so that i can help the land
be cleared of this plague i need
knowledge and teresius says to him
you sure you want that you know my lord
i don't think you want to know the
answer to this saying no i need to know
that is part of how his character is
bestimped given determination right it's
not just
starting as a cool guy and then you know
everything flows from that it is the
choices that are being made and this
leads to the next thing activity
battegan right coming from the word uh
tun tat right that we've encountered so
many times action right activity no
longer just handle
betting or the tethygong
which is a different term
and then the
actuality
right
the actuality is the vehicle kite being
made
something in the world the narrative
world the world that exists on this
basis of spectator consciousness
so he says that um
that the heroes find in
their consciousness in these powers in
uh
doing the things that they do in in
being part of the story and they become
these these powers right so this is how
the notion the concept is broken apart
for those who are looking on
and in a certain way buy they're looking
on participating in the creation
of a story
the content and movement of spirit which
here is object to itself has already
been considered as the nature and
realization of the ethical substance
in its religion it attains to a
consciousness of itself or exhibits
itself to consciousness in its purer
form and its simpler embodiment
if then the ethical substance and virtue
of its notions split itself as regards
its content into powers which were
defined as divine in human law or law of
the nether and of the upper world the
one the family the other the state power
the first being the feminine the second
the masculine character
similarly now the previously
multi-formed circle of gods with its
fluctuating characteristics confines
itself to these powers which are thereby
brought closer to genuine individuality
for the previous dispersion of the whole
and into manifold and abstract forces
which appear
hypostatized in the dissolution of the
subject which comprehends them only as
moments within itself so that
individuality is merely the super
superficial form of these entities
conversely a further distinction of
characters than that just named is to be
attributed to contingent and
intrinsically external personality
in paragraph 736 we see hegel doing
something that he's done many times
before
in the phenomenology
looking back from the vantage point of
having come a certain distance
in the dialectical development of
consciousness and self-consciousness
back
at previous sections previous stages
previous shapes previous dialectics in
which we were doing something quite
similar and in this section it makes
perfect sense since we're talking about
greek tragedy that he is going to be
looking back primarily
to the early part of the spirit section
in which we were using something like a
exposition of the antigone
to make sense out of some important
cultural developments that went beyond
just greek culture
and you know the specific situation of
thebes to talk about some some major
developments
in general and so hegel tells us that
the content the inhalt right and the
movement the beveling of spirit
which here is object to itself gagen
stand right it takes itself as an object
that it can look at spirit is you might
say projecting itself out of itself in
this complex way
that's part of what's happening
in the in the putting something up on
the stage
in greek tragedy and also on the part of
the
artist who now is no longer just a
counselor somebody you know working on
statues no longer just the minstrel the
bard of the gezenga right of the epic
but the tragedy and the playwright who
is is constructing this
representation this performance this
foreshadowing for
us and this is happening in uh this part
of religion so he says um here his
object itself has already been
considered has already been thought out
has already been looked at
in as the nature nature and realization
now here it's interesting it's not very
looking in or anything like that it's
quite simply the cognate realization
right making real in a different way
than making actual
this you know when we talk about a
producer
of artistic
works particularly in terms of film and
we think about the realizer of it it's
the one who brings it to the the stage
or to the screen or to the streaming
medium these days and makes it possible
for us to
see it and i think we could look at it
in this way it's a little anachronistic
to read that in but
i think that works
so he says
the nature and realization of what the
ethical substance the
substance that we've been uh talking
about throughout really
the second part of the reasons section
all the way into spirit and now into
religion
so he says that in its religion now
notice that term there he doesn't say
in religion
right in its religion zine
right this is an important
uh point it's not just in religion per
se it's in
this particular
mode of religion and you know we're
looking at greek tragedy here but we
might also think about passion plays we
might also think about
other depictions other kinds of drama
which are dealing with heroic characters
heroic in some sense perhaps saintly
characters in some senses and the gods
or the spiritual powers right
so he goes on and he says
in its religion
it attains to a consciousness of itself
or
exhibits itself to consciousness
in its purer form and its simpler
embodiment so there's there's something
that has
changed something that has become
refined purified
along the way
from what and this is where we raise
kind of an interesting question well
back in the spirit section
weren't we talking about greek tragedy i
mean bringing in the antigone
as you know one of the high points of
sophocles and uh tragedy
um
you know
how are we how are we not already
engaging with greek drama at that point
and hegel could say well you know it
wasn't as refined what we were doing in
spirit is really less about the drama
itself and much more
about the things that it was supposed to
be depicting the
social struggles the
uh direction you know enzyme that we
talked about in the last
paragraph
and so he says if the ethical substance
in virtue of its notion virtue of its
concept
split itself as regards its content the
inhalt
into powers which were defined and now
he goes through a whole sequence divine
and human law
or the law of the nether in the upper
world the one the family the other the
state power the first being the feminine
the second the masculine character okay
so that's what was going on in that
early spirit section right uh where we
talked about these two different laws
and again depicted in the antigone
refined in hegel's analysis of it
seemingly present there in greek and
many other societies
he goes on and he says similarly now so
in greek tragedy in the religious aspect
of it
we have something else going on
now i want to come back to something in
the previous paragraph
we mentioned that there's this
very
common hegelian
let's call it
feature or shtick
of wanting to focus on duality
rather than on multiplicity as such why
because multiplicity
is really kind of a mess it's hard to
manage things emerge you know this is
this is not for example nietzsche or
duluz or anybody else who's looking at
hegel and saying this is very dualistic
a lot of the time
hegel does have a preference for this
and he says that this previous
multi-form so a multiplicity mounting
faulty kite
circle christ of of gods of of deities
that we talked about in previous
paragraphs this previous kind of messy
you know
set of overlapping narratives where the
gods are this the gods are that
hegel views that as rather abstract
it becomes crystallized into the tragedy
in a way that we'll talk about so the
previous multiple multiformed circle of
gods with fluctuating characteristics
confines itself now this is important
there's two different
let's call them filterings or
restrictions it's not that that stuff
isn't there
right and hegel's saying get rid of it
censor it suppress it he says just
saying no
there's this natural process of zeroing
in
on things being on two sides
i mean we can think about the iliad for
example right as a prime example of this
you have two sides that the gods both
take part in as well as the heroes of
course you know there's always the risk
of falling into
multiplicity within the greek camp right
agamemnon and achilles are at odds with
each other
ajax hates the guts out of it out of
odysseus and we go on and on and on
so he says here
these are brought close
they are confining themselves to these
powers
which are thereby brought closer to
genuine
not just plain old but genuine
individuality right individuality here
is the same individual individuality
that was talked about in the previous
paragraph
so now it is singular right they are
being brought to or abstract you could
say to
um eigenly
genuine real individuality
and he says the previous dispersion
again a multiplicity is a dispersion
into manifold manifold
money faulty right and abstract
forces
which appeared hypostatized meaning
this is a translation here of uh were
present as substances right
is the dissolution of the subject and
here it's subject right which
comprehends them only as moments within
itself so that individuality is merely
the superficial form of these entities
this sounds suspiciously
like
nietzsche's birth of tragedy and talking
about what's going on from you might say
the dionysian point of view except that
of course the birth of tragedy is
written decades after this so hagel
already has his finger on something that
is going to come up in that great work
which nietzsche says is too hegelian by
the way and it says comprehends them
only as moments within itself
individuality is merely the superficial
form of these entities conversely hegel
says a further distinction of characters
than that just named is to be attributed
to contingent zhu feligas an
intrinsically external personality
personality something different than
individuality right and so contingent
zoophilian and intrinsically external on
zeke
austerliken right
so there's a filtering here a
concentration going on
that is to some degree you know we could
say it's artificial
important voices are being left out but
they're being left out because
either they're you know too many
different voices at the same time or
because they are merely contingent we
want tragedy
ancient greeks want a tragedy to talk
about something
universal something that appeals
to
[Music]
us as spectators to get to see
a story that isn't just about schmucks
like us
and may impart some some wisdom or offer
some possibility for as aristotle
pointed out and as we talked about in a
few paragraphs earlier catharsis
purification
from affects of what what is it that the
audience feels
pity
and fear
so there's a lot going on in this
introduction
of the chorus and this moving back to
talking about the
subject of tragedy which is involving
this this sort of narrowing in
on who the key players
the key played really the key characters
are going to be
you